Tony hey Rich thanks for picking up my
call
happy New Year all awesome happy New
Year
um about a month ago um my wife called
the cops uh I got arrested uh for
assault uh unfortunately
um
I hire a lawyer I hire a criminal lawyer
I'm also hire a family lawyer um I guess
right now it's kind of Christmas
all days
um I felt that the lawyers are pretty
sluggish okay the past two weeks I was I
was asking if I can amend the
restraining order to see my my kids okay
obviously the wife refused
uh just wondering if you can give me
some advice whether I hire how do I how
do I find if how do I know if I hire a
bright lawyer where do you live for
instance uh Southern Ontario
I mean
I've got a great family lawyer but he
doesn't want any more clients right now
he's winding down his business
um
look
the stuff that I talk about when it
comes to dealing with family law and
dealing with divorce and dealing with DV
charges is it a false TV or is it one
that you actually committed
uh well she was throwing a fit uh
throwing stuff around the house and I
pinned her down that was it yeah that's
enough yeah that's enough
um I mean he didn't hurt her obviously
but he just pinned her down and get her
to stop throwing [ __ ] at you basically
yeah
yeah that's enough
um
yeah so Tony I'm like here's the thing I
mean
had you followed the stuff that I talked
about in my book and the stuff that I
just put in the course which I know what
wasn't available you wouldn't have
pinned her down you would have instead
taken your cell phone backed up filmed
her while she was having a complete
meltdown in a strong [ __ ] at you and had
evidence in case she did want to file a
false DB because then you could show it
to the cops and be like look crazy [ __ ]
was throwing [ __ ] all I did was walk out
of the room you can see your hand out
with a camera and that's what you did
but I don't have a time machine to take
you back so the only advice that I have
is follow whatever your lawyer tells you
to do do you have money
I have enough for uh for the criminal
lawyer and the family lawyer at this
time yes like it could like in Ontario
could take 20 30 40 Grand right like do
you have enough money for that uh yeah
yeah 20 34 yeah I do yeah all right well
go through all the due process then I
mean you're gonna have to follow all the
steps but that's just the reality of a
false DV charge brother I mean there's
nothing else that I can really offer you
you know at this point it's it's really
strategies to avoid what happened to
Tony that I talk about in my course
because it can happen to anybody if you
don't know like you didn't know that
this could happen to you like you didn't
know because she's throwing [ __ ] at you
and all you do is you stand up and
you're a strong masculine men you pin
her down to get her to stop it you
didn't know that that could get you
taken out of the house in handcuffs
right
yeah so it's like you know you don't
know what you don't know and that's just
one of the problems one of the risks
that that guys have to contend with one
of many
Tony I don't have a time machine so
you're gonna follow your lawyer on this
and spend some money to fix it but yeah
it is what it is it's it's incredibly
important you try to avoid it so this is
more of a lesson of you know why you
need to know these things
any any advice whether I hire a right
lawyer or a wrong lawyer is there a
um I'd look for a guy that's got at
least 10 15 years of experience because
you're dealing with a false DV charge I
would ask him how successful he is with
false DV charges
um I would probably look him up on
Canley so one of the things you can do
right now yourself so here's some advice
because you live in Ontario is go to
canley.org c-a-n-l-i-i dot o-r-g yeah
and then and then start searching for
um domestic violence as a keyword and
then I would start reading all case law
that you can find with false domestic
violence charges to get yourself up on
up to speed on how Ontario courts handle
DV charges
right but you should be able to rely on
a lawyer that's that's done it so ask
him how long he's practiced how many DV
charges he's dealt with how many false
DV charges he's gotten dropped or lifted
and you know gotten the dad access back
in the house into his kids and all that
sort of stuff
um so I mean you got some work in front
of you unfortunately but uh
um that's just you know that's just
reality of divorce man that's just what
happens to a lot of guys uh but you'll
be fine at the end of it yeah I'm still
in uh shell shocking uh you know talk
like talk to your friends talk to your
siblings if you have them you know don't
don't sit there and fester you know by
yourself but
um you're going to be down on yourself
for a bit that's fine okay the good news
is you have the money to fight it I mean
there's guys that that end up in a very
similar type of scenario and they don't
have a pot to piston or a winner to
throw it out of and they just get
destroyed so the good news is you have
money to fight it so that's one of the
things I included in my courses I told
guys if you're planning to get divorced
make sure sure you have a Honeypot in
case she pulls a false TV on you so that
you can pay your way through it and I
get in all those details in it but yeah
that's what I would do man so spend some
time on Canley tonight after this
canley.org and start reading case law on
um domestic violence or false domestic
violence charges I think of your time
Rich com can also have that email list I
want to join that um the course of the
for the divorce oh yeah uh get on the
list because you want to grab that uh
it's down there so it's entrepreneurs
and cars.com forward slash red Dash
Flags okay gotcha thank you very much
Rich okay bud say good night I really
hope you guys enjoyed that clip if you
want to watch the full length podcast
you can find that over here that clips
from if you're new to the channel make
sure you hit subscribe over here and pin
down below in the top comment you'll
find a bunch of useful links to my
website my supplement line books and a
bunch of other stuff have an amazing day
peace out